White's winning it's made for white
where's the mate though I don't know but
it's gotta be there oh my God
oh my gosh
oh
go cash D may be the rising chess star
of 2022. he's gained a host of rating
points and surged past 2700 at the age
of just 16. a historic achievement
gukesh also beat Magnus Carlson in the
meltwater tour in the only decisive game
that the two have ever played
though Carlson was doubtless a heavy
favorite in his Opening match against
gukesh fans were excited to see what
dense the youngster could make in the
world champions renowned defenses
Carlson is big on setting the tone early
in matches and game one was an excellent
display from the world champion who
pressed gukesh's isolated Pawn until a
little tactic picked it off he smoothly
converted now it's over now he's just
going after all the Pawns
two seconds for gokashan he's simply
going to resign in his first game with
the white pieces though gukesh also
showed that he has teeth as he claimed a
large Advantage offering an unacceptable
night sacrifice on F5 and finding key
accurate shots I think C5 ends and he
finds he goes for it gukesh finds it
seven seconds for the champ oh and he's
all in now he's like well might as well
take now look H5 Rook G5 1-0 it's over
it's over oh my lands what a game
ukesh says not so fast go and brush your
shoulder off youngster it's a match baby
not so fast everyone big pressure from
Magnus against a terrible Pawn structure
in game three was well defended by
gukesh Magnus sank into long thought as
it seemed the win might have eluded him
okay he he goes for I think Magnus will
will risk it
he likes those biscuits here it comes I
actually really like your point of B4
wait I think beat okay it's not B4 now
now it's the line we were talking about
there must be something concrete
similar to The Rook switching to the
e-file like you already highlighted and
easy Carlson even appeared frustrated by
Gucci's error in that finale his seeming
frustration was only furthered by the
next game where he let a big Advantage
slip and was nearly losing when he
complicated things with an exchange
sacrifice
at that pressure this is where blunders
happen you ever wondering the bumper
sticker blunders happen
wonders happen right here when you've
got your king in the middle of the board
no but gouquet should have taken with a
rook on e4 he gave up that pawn on C4
and he let the bishops get active and
now Bishop E3 and Bishop D3
wait what wait is it blue The Mating net
yup Bishop B3 oh dude would be one Rook
F1 was made oh my God that was made in
two you called it rugby what Rook if it
was me and he's gonna have it again look
up one yeah but Bishop B3 is winning too
just stroke A1 Rook A1
I'm surprised Magnus missed it what in
the world just happened there
oh my God now Carlson seemed to have the
wind of the sails and he delivered more
wins in games five six and seven with
convincing play the eighth game showed
that even though Carlson may not have
been tactically on point his positional
skills were more than enough to continue
winning games every point you push can't
go back becomes a weakness the blunder
Knight D3 the blundered Knight D3
winning the exchange or don't tell me
Magnus is going to miss it oh he did
walk down he misses it Magnus is missing
tactics today it's crazy but he again
he's still winning he's like the same
narrative repeating itself over and over
again he's so positionally dominant
Danny that he can afford to miss this
stuff and still win there's no way he
prolongs this game that long though you
can take G4 and then take H6 okay no he
doesn't
with enough time for one final five plus
one Blitz game Carlson seemed only
Loosely focused as he easily won again
finishing the time control with eight
wins and one loss the word adoption
began to be tossed around in chat what's
what state game so long Rook D3 is the
easiest move the whole game Rook D3
Knight F4 Queen H6 team G8 Rook G3 king
of seven Queen oh there was Queen H7 and
Bishop B5 checked and he missed Bishop
B5 at the end maybe that was it
I'm in Rook D3 Bishop C8 though uh but
then Rook G3 is over nah it's over okay
it's over whoa another nice opening win
by Carlson was followed by a curious
sequence in which Carlson did a double
take as gookash caught him off guard
take it might have been a mouse that
might have been a mouse club actually
like he meant to play C4
I mean
and kukash took a while there too
that'll wake you up you see that oh whoa
and if you go Bishop E7 then gukesh
should go Rook to D7 here
it happened it's over wow no adoption
for the second time in the match gukesh
had won the second game in the time
control and once again he appeared
poised to win again in the following
game when they're ensued an insane time
scramble one second two seconds oh Rook
G4 H oh my god 98. I think I'm going to
promote you at night I was thinking that
too but not the same matter
oh my God what a heartbreaker for gukesh
such a painful time forfeit is hard to
return from and Carlson kept up the
pressure in the next game as he first
sacrificed on G4 and then on F2 there
are Zero moves oh he goes right we're
gonna see it on the board we're gonna do
Madness finds it oh he finishes in style
three more clean wins from Carlson led
into possibly the most exciting game of
the entire match as in game 8 gukesh
came out aggressively with G3 and then
G4 in the opening he got a big attack
and he came close close to a winning
Advantage as things got chaotic after a
transition to the end game Carlson was
suddenly the one getting winning chances
here comes the a pawn here's Johnny oh
King A1 and there's a Salesman give up
the bishop no he's gonna fly again
ah okay it's obviously Magnus wouldn't
take the bishop even if he offered it
G6
White's winning it's made for white
where's the mate though I don't know but
it's gotta be there oh my God oh
my gosh
oh Carlson laughing off victory in the
penultimate game was a sign of things to
come as he found himself again laughing
after a less satisfactory finish to the
three plus one time control
just Queen takes D4 even as simple
resign time
93 no then Rook takes D3 Rook takes C1
yep
good calculation yep
with the honor goal in the final game
of the three minute portion building off
his Blitz ending Victory gookesh struck
in the bullet with the brilliant Queen
takes H6 and Lucas could absolutely
check my Magnus here oh wait Queen H6 we
did six in the back oh Magnus rolls his
head
to follow up he goes 94. for the first
time in the match gookesh had won
back-to-back games but Carlson
immediately rebounded with back-to-back
wins of his own the next game Saw gukesh
claimed a big edge with black but
Carlson turned things around and nearly
had the opportunity to under promote to
a bishop with mate in the final position
it's a problem it's not Donald Trump F6
Dirty Dancing
Bishop c72
sick King takes F6 d8 equals Bishop mate
mate
omg's or snaps under promoting to a
bishop for me two more consecutive
Carlson wins saw a sudden and unexpected
reversal it's just brutal to face Magnus
Carlson in some of your first online
Blitz chests in a while Magnus is having
some internet problems he's gonna flag
this one out
he's lagging out
a delay as Carlson reconnected saw the
champion return and saw his hair
escalating in grandiosity as the chat
was enthusiastic to note
gukesh capitalized on the time forfeit
win with one of his most convincing wins
over the board the follow-up game though
was a funny one as gukesh was hungering
to deliver Checkmate on F6 right oh
other way over here it comes
yeah but you're oh you're threatening 97
so maybe just yeah whoa 27 made he
bloody kids stuff made oh my God
this high water mark for good cash three
consecutive wins was ended by two
convincing Carlson wins as gukesh
resigned the next game quickly after he
lost a knight he clearly wanted one more
final game against the world champion
with 30 seconds left on the match clock
wait yes yes he wants one more just
resign one more game with the world
champion after an even 30 Games Carlson
won by 16 over his young Indian opponent
and that's how it ends folks he is
locked into play another match against
his rival Fabiano caruana in the speed
Chess Championship quarterfinals
although his victory was overwhelming
Carlson himself was by no means either
happy or impressed with it
um I didn't enjoy today's match one bit
uh I felt like I was playing
horribly from the stars I just didn't
have it at all I mean he's a very strong
player but he has no experience playing
yeah
especially online and you know It's a
combination of
experience and innate ability that's
still there even when I suck
yep
[Music]